Speaker 1: Well, ladies and gentlemen, we
had primaries last night.
And as expected, Wyoming Republican Congresswoman
Liz Cheney has been absolutely, brutally defeated
in her Republican primary.
Did she abandon Republican orthodoxy?
Was she pro-choice or against lowering taxes
on the rich or any policy?
No, it wasn't anything like that.
She simply said that Donald Trump really did
lose the election in 2020 and for that the
MAGA people determined that she had to be
punished and she will now be replaced on the
November final general election ballot by
Harriet Hagaman, an individual whose political
views are essentially identical to Liz Cheney's.
With the exception that Harriet Hagaman has
parroted the claim that Joe Biden didn't really
win in November of 2020.
And that apparently was a mortal sin.
Let's talk about last night's primaries.
As the Associated Press reports, Trump Fired
Cheney Loses Wyoming GOP Primary Ponders 2024
Bid.
I don't even care about the 2024 thing for
now.
She was on with Savannah Guthrie this morning
and sort of said, I'm going to think about
24.
There's no real need to talk about that right
now.
A lot of things will happen between now and
then.
Liz Cheney, Trump's fiercest Republican adversary,
writes The AP in Congress soundly lost a Republican
primary, failing but falling to a rival backed
by the former president in a rout that reinforced
his grip on the party's base.
The third term congresswoman and her allies
entered Tuesday downbeat about her prospects.
And listen, she lost.
I mean, I don't even really know what else
we need to pull from this.
She lost and she lost very, very significantly.
And the reason that she became a target of
the MAGA people and of Donald Trump is that
she insisted Trump didn't win in 2020.
Trump really genuinely lost.
She's still a Republican.
She still voted the way Trump wanted.
93% of the time when she was in Congress and
Trump was president.
But she says no.
Trump genuinely did lose.
And in her concession speech, sort of her
or her speech that she gave, she says, I easily
won last time.
I could have won again.
I just would have had to lie and say that
Trump won and I wasn't willing to do that.
Let's listen to what she had to say last night.
Speaker 2: Two years ago, I won this primary
with 73% of the vote.
Speaker 1: True.
Speaker 2: I could easily have done the same
again.
The path was clear, but it would have required
that I go along with President Trump's lie
about the 2020 election.
It would have required that I enable his ongoing
efforts to unravel our democratic system and
attack the foundations of our Republic.
That was a path I could not and would not
take.
Speaker 1: The Lincoln Project commented on
Liz Cheney's primary loss.
That's a group made of sort of non-Trump Republicans
for the most part.
And they said tonight marks the end of the
Republican Party.
What remains share is the name of the Republican
Party.
But it is, in fact, an authoritarian nationalist
cult dedicated only to Donald Trump.
So there's really two sides to this.
Is it wacky and is it disturbing that this
is what the Republican Party has become?
Of course it is.
Of course, it's wacky and disturbing.
The goal of the MAGA people is to purge the
Republican Party of the critics of Donald
Trump, even something as benign as saying
the results were the real results Joe Biden
did when Donald Trump did lose.
You've got Adam Kinzinger retiring.
Liz Cheney lost her primary.
Some of the other Republicans who did vote
to convict Trump on that second impeachment
trial are either retiring or lost primaries.
So it is absolutely crazy that that's the
situation at the same time.
It's important to remind you that Liz Cheney
mostly voted with Trump and she's being replaced
by someone who will mostly vote in the way
that Trump would want will vote with the Republican
Party.
Whatever.
Harriet Hagaman will vote the same way as
Liz Cheney on just about every issue.
The only difference is Hagaman is willing
to repeat the big lie.
Whereas Liz Cheney was not so.
It's also disturbing because on policy there
is essentially no difference between Hagaman
and Cheney.
They're both against abortion.
They're both for, you know, lower taxes for
the rich, whatever.
The difference is actually just one about
this issue where it's about an election that
was almost two years ago.
So that's also sad.
Now, these results could potentially backfire.
And I'll mention the way in which that could
happen.
Wyoming's total population is 580,000.
No, I'm not saying 580,000 people voted yesterday.
I'm not saying that's 580,000 Republicans.
The total population of Wyoming is 580,000.
Tiny electorate much more subject to having
a primary manipulated by out-of-state money
and Trump and the MAGA people.
These results could send a signal to the more
reasonable Republicans in other parts of the
country to the extent that they exist and
to a little extent they do that the Republican
Party is now the MAGA Party, and many Republicans
aren't at all in favor of this being a MAGA
Party.
If you're Mitt Romney, for example, it is
at this point, thanks to the Democratic Party,
that we still even have some semblance of
democracy in the United States.
But if you're Romney, you should understand
that your own party will come for you, at
least potentially.
And we have to see what the impact is of that
on to the extent that they exist.
The more moderate and reasonable Republicans.
Now, couple other elections from last night.
Lisa murkowski also was challenged by a pro-Trump
Republican in Alaska in the Senate.
She won enough votes to advance to the general
election in November in that Senate race.
And Sarah Palin, although she did not get
the most votes in her Alaska congressional
primary yesterday.
She also will advance to November.
So that's what's going on.
And we're going to have these.
It's an open House seat for Sarah Palin.
And we will see in November what happens with
that.
But very disturbing results, that's for sure